des campagnes de vaccination ont ralenti
alors que bruxelles a autorisé le vaccin
astrazeneca ce vendredi depuis plusieurs
jours l'europe doit composer avec des
retards de livraison de vaccins
particulièrement dans le viseur de
bruxelles
astrazeneca qui a récemment annoncé une
baisse de 60% des doses qui lui était
initialement destinée afin de mettre le
géant pharmaceutique face à ses
responsabilités
l'union européenne a rendu public ce
vendredi le contrat qui lie les deux
parties
une publication qui intervient alors que
l'agencé européenne du médicament a
approuvé l'utilisation du vaccin
d'astrazeneca pour les plus de 18 ans
l'allemagne émet des réserves sur cette
décision
nous ne comptons pas sur une approbation
sans restriction le débat de ces
derniers jours et que nous n'avons pas
suffisamment de données sur les
personnes âgées pour le faire soit dit
en passant la question est plutôt de
savoir si les données sont suffisantes
ou non il est important à mon avis de
communiqué qu'un vaccin approuvé est
également efficace pour le groupe pour
lequel il est approuvé et recommandé
mais le vaccin britannique n'est pas le
seul à connaître des retards de
livraisons à destination de l'union
européenne modern haifa isr ont
également annoncé des baisses
d'approvisionnement qui impactent
fortement la campagne de vaccination
conséquence directe de nombreux pays
sont contraints de repousser les primo
injection prévues dans les semaines à
venir
face à cette situation bruxelles à
adopter en urgence un texte qui vise à
contrôler les exportations de vaccins
objectif empêcher la sortie de doses
prévues pour le continent aujourd'hui la
commission a adopté un mécanisme qui
rend l'export de certains produits
soumis à une autorisation d'exportation
ce mécanisme concerne la transparence de
l'export des vaccins contre le coc vie
cette mesure nous l'avons prise dans la
plus grande urgence
le but est de fournir immédiatement une
totale transparence une
ans par an ce qui est jusqu'ici manque
et que les européens attendent
et si besoin cela nous donnera également
un levier pour permettre la livraison
des vaccins alors que bruxelles se
démène pour faire respecter les contrats
signés avec plusieurs laboratoires
certains pays ont opté pour d'autres
solutions
c'est le cas notamment pour la hongrie
membres de l'union européenne
après avoir donné son feu vert pour
l'utilisation du vaccin russe tout nick
v budapest vient d'approuver le sérum du
groupe chinois sinopharm